hello
everyone and thanks for watching this
week we are talking about fitness that's
right it's fitness week and we have with
us
brian loftus hi rocky
in honor of in honor of fitness week we
are on the second
story here i did run up the stairs and
i'm gonna uh
try try to avoid in and out this week so
just in honor of fitness
i will try to avoid it don't worry about
it we're gonna start
with what you and your family do to stay
healthy here's our first video
okay let's take a look this is uh one of
the things
i do with my two daughters well first of
all they do i should say
you can see this is not something i
could do in a million years they
they're able to jump in the air she
didn't even use her hands there come on
that's just showing off
basically i'm just standing there with
the pooch and holding a cell phone
documenting their incredible athleticism
but
two really active girls love being a
girl dad
daughters rock everybody out there with
daughters knows that although sons rock
too of course
so i love doing active stuff with them
because you don't want kids
to be stuck in front of the screen or
netflix or video games you try to get
them
moving as much as possible because
frankly it's good for them right and i
have
video footage of that too of you joining
in yes
this is our family bike ride you know
what this was rocky early in the
pandemic
when things shut down i became the de
facto p.e teacher
so every day i was like okay what
activities can we do i just want those
of you watching on social media to know
that yes my head is actually that large
rocky
did not blow that up on your screen
i do have a five head it's too large to
be considered a forehead so
what we would do for pe is go on bike
rides go on hikes
and do all kinds of activities because
remember
it was shut down you couldn't go to
school they didn't have gym class
so you're trying to kind of go hey let's
keep
the the flow of what they normally would
be doing and uh we all love riding bikes
and so
this is what we do it looks great you
know the biggest challenge there was
holding the cell phone and not falling
over well yeah i'm doing a little video
there while i'm holding while i'm riding
along
i had no one you know there was no
photographer there so okay well here we
go check this one out
all right oh this is wiffle ball you
can't go wrong with some wiffle ball
yeah it's i'm i'm the designated
all-time pitcher
that's uh my nine-year-old who is uh i i
find it interesting she ripped a sweet
shot to right field and never ran to
first base
she just kind of walked it off like pops
what's up that was a babe ruth call
i'm gonna just stroll towards you yeah
that was uh
that's a little end of a cul-de-sac so
you have no traffic and so you can have
an unfettered game of wiffle ball which
by the way
may be the most underrated game in the
history of sports
next seriously if you have a barbecue or
picnic
get some wiffle ball going everybody
loves it love it thanks
and here's a slideshow yes awesome
girl dad we love to paddle board this is
at lake las vegas and and when back in
the midwest we do a lot of paddle
boarding
this is hiking at icebox canyon and this
is zion
another hiking weekend as you can as you
can see there i just try to keep up with
them
and then of course you know i grew up in
chicago below zero weather i love to get
out and do a little cold weather
mount charleston sledding when the
season is right
so they are they're super active they
keep me going i try to just keep up with
them
they keep getting more and more athletic
as they get really into their sports of
dance and soccer
uh both of which i am average to below
average we've all seen my rhythmless
dancing on new year's eve so
i did give her five dollars for that
compliment and you hit the mark
perfectly
thank you thanks for joining us today
[Music]
hockey i have a confession it's fitness
week and i had an in and out double
double today
i just want to come clean i want to
point out something we were talking
about briefly before we went on air you
were saying how you
see me getting my steps in in the
parking lot i just kind of randomly walk
around during my work shift
you thought he's rather contemplative
he's just walking aimlessly i actually
think rocky might have thought i was
looking for my car
uh but no it is just somehow to get you
never you never can do it quite
consistently but to get those steps in
because we sit so much right as are we
right now i'm about to go do the
five o'clock newscast okay and we said
so it's a way to get moving
well thank you so much for joining us
andreas all week at 6 a.m we're talking
about fitness
thanks brian rocky thank you thanks for
having me we'll see you all here in the
comments
where what you do to stay active